joe biden was made to look really bad
today all right
when antifa was was trending on twitter
and settled in portland
and uh well they had to take action so
we got this tweet from andy no breaking
twitter has suspended several prominent
antifa accounts
the base brooklyn is one of them the
base is an extremist bookstore in
brooklyn new york that has been used as
an anti-for training center
sixteen thousand eight hundred followers
gone
we also have m f g m the jewish worker
30
000 followers gone revolutionary
abolitionist movement
11 000 400 followers gone and rev
abolition nyc gone and i think these are
just a few that andy has highlighted i'm
sure there's a lot more
and this is well like we mentioned
earlier they're throwing away what they
don't need anymore
it's making them look bad they need to
get rid of it and uh
you know what i'll say this if they were
advocating violence
if they were organizing violence ban
them get rid of them
if they were just tweeting stupid
opinions then i still think the
censorship is bad
i don't care if it's the left or the
right but you know when the biggest
problems with all of the censorship
stuff is
there was there's a left wing podcast
that got nuked on on youtube
i'm not gonna name them and immediately
you know what i see
i see the libertarians i see the free
speech advocates the anti-sjw's all
defending them saying hey hey reinstate
them yep
but then what happens when it's say you
know count dankula gets mass demonetized
they go hahaha serves you right but i'm
a private business
that's a problem you know when someone
when you get when you get a person like
count dankula
who will act with honor and integrity
and stand up for principle
and his adversaries will not we are all
at a disadvantage when we're fair
and respect people and their rights to
free speech that being said
these people i believe were pro i
wouldn't be surprised if they were
organizing actual violence
you know they like to point to right
wingers and they say i see this on
reddit all the time
well maybe you shouldn't send death
threats to people and they wouldn't have
deleted parlor and it's like dude
there was i think 60 posts out of
hundreds of thousands
just in like a period like an hour
period that were violent
all right i'm sorry i should say there
are probably millions of posts and 60
all together that were considered to be
like harsh death threats
so they nuked the entire company come on
man that doesn't make sense
twitter is loaded with extremist
propaganda and calls for violence and
it's protected
so if you were to tell me that people on
parlor were sending you know death
threats whatever i'd be like oh yeah
it's a good thing they were banning them
but that's not everybody and if you tell
me antifa was doing it i'd be like
yeah are they going to ban them and then
they're going to cry follow and they're
going to start saying
we're the free speech activists to
defend our free speech the one thing i
really love about all this stuff is
when i see the tweets on the leftist and
they're like where are all the free
speech warriors now
to to complain about the censorship of
those criticizing israel
and i'm like bro we've all been
defending your free speech too the
entire time
and when it happens we always speak up
about it and then when it happens to us
they laugh so what do you do
i even remember arguing arguing with
them years ago
when people were being banned uh
independent media people on the right
and they were celebrating it i'm like
you guys don't understand
the hammer is going to come after you
very
very soon here it is it's only going to
get worse and and this is what happens
when you cheer on for a sm
for a few small select individuals to
have the ultimate power of controlling
speech it's a huge power it's going to
be used and abused
if you're standing in the way of the
cogs of the machines if you're not in
the right position if you're not
reiterating the right talking points at
the right time
you're going to be axed no matter who
you are and it's coming everywhere
i think it was glenn greenwald who said
it best i think this was
i think it's his quote that if there's
any group of people that fails to learn
from past mistakes it's liberals
advocating for censorship
because it always recoils back on them
and it's true for antifa now getting
nuked they were all cheering for it well
goodbye
when you talk about censorship and
antifa violence it's like a demon
that is like free me and i will destroy
your enemies yeah
all you have to do is release me from
these chains and trust me
yes and you're like that's mark
zuckerberg no no he's and then you
release the demon he kills your enemies
and then he tries and then he kills you
it's like it's like you know yeah you
ever see aladdin
when when jafar wishes he's a genie and
then they did
the the uh the part two for like
straight to home dvd jafar is a genie
now and he's like wish me free it's like
yeah you're evil and if we unleash this
you're gonna hurt everybody
but you know what man some people don't
care it's they don't know no no
you know what it is it's the one ring
it's it's it's watching a lot of lord of
the rings lately
auntie was boromir right and he's like
censorship is a gift
we should wield it against our enemies
you can't control it
no one can that's exactly what happened
and they didn't get it
and now they're getting nuked but i
think a lot of them is ignorant so we
can you know
just spread the knowledge about the
dangerous censorship that helps a lot
not everyone's malicious a lot of people
are ignorant i saw a cartoon today where
uh it's four guys in a boat and two guys
are on one end
bailing the boat out because there's a
leak at the other end and the other two
guys at the other end of the boat are
like haha well i'm glad you know this
isn't affecting us
oh cause it's raised up right exactly
yeah they're like floating in the boat
sinking
yeah yeah that's the the world they seek
to create but
i'll tell you what's interesting about
this so uh i'll just show you this real
quick this is literally what antifa is
doing
today you know we we mentioned this in
the previous segment we don't want biden
we want
revenge and there's what looks like is
that is that an ak
yeah it looks like an ak i could be
wrong um
but this uh the organization the base is
is based in new york they have a
public-facing website all this
information is readily available in
public they have their open hours
they say the basis in anarchist
political center in bushwick brooklyn
committed to the dissemination of
revolutionary left and anarchist ideas
and organizing
now on their website it's very you know
innocuous right
well project veritas actually did an
expose
i don't i don't know if i've actually
actually had the full expose well here's
an opinion piece about it or something
where they've they had footage from
inside where they were doing
combat training basically you know the
self-defense training you're allowed to
do soft
self-defense training totally totally
acceptable i took a kung fu class once
that's right i did yeah we had to fight
with the sticks it was really cool
long time ago no no no it's called
something else because there's two of
them and you hold them like that
and we did this like they do this really
fast you know fighting stuff
so that's fine but there is an issue
when you've got
advocacy for violence when you've got
evidence that these
these groups in new york have been
violent and they're teaching people
about revolutionary ideas
and they hold extremist views and then
they train for violence
you add all those things together and i
wouldn't be surprised if they're posting
really really bad stuff
it's gonna get banned would it be good
though if we knew what they posted that
they got banned for yeah
like i've maybe it was innocuous maybe
it was something that um
crosses the line i mean we have no idea
it's always the mystery with these guys
there's no transparency in the banning
process
and that that is a problem and that's
why i typically am opposed to it no
matter what
well but i i guess you got to draw the
line if they're saying like go do a
thing you know what i mean
so we should at least know what they
said and and to have
full transparency and accountability
from these big tech networks that are
literally
having the most important power in the
world destroying
anything that that could be made up
it's such a catch-20 i don't know if
it's catch-22 or it's just a
a hard situation because if they said
something that's going to radicalize
people they want to prevent people from
seeing it
but if they prevent people from seeing
it then we can't verify
that what they did was wrong exactly the
problem is that they shouldn't get to
choose
what is going to radicalize someone
every idea should be held equally valid
unless it's explicitly calling for
violence against someone
so every idea should be out well and
that and if it was
actually calling for violence it's not
that's not actually legally protected
speech exactly
either i mean because the law is pretty
clear in fact um
actually if i can jump in here and say
something about uh
this problem i actually came here
tonight with the solution
to this problem oh yes a solution a
solution to solutions
we don't talk about that yeah all we do
is complain it is
i agree with you it's much easier to
complain but but i have the solution i
brought it with me
um to text censorship to de-platforming
to getting blacklisted by financial
firms and it's very simple we have to
sort of look
where do we have strength still because
you know the senate's gone the house is
gone
by this in the control progressives um
we don't know where the supreme court is
but where we still have a lot of
allies and people supporting us in fact
in the majority of the state
legislatures
so i believe that the solution is
state-level
state legislation that prevents the
state and any government
within the state that's counties cities
etc from engaging in business
with the social networks that censor
with tech companies that de-platform
with um with financial institutions that
blacklist people
because look we kind of agree we're all
on the side it's your company you run
the social network you can decide who's
on it and who isn't right
but you're not entitled to tax money
paid by people who you are deplatforming
whom you're getting fired
whom you're throwing off your service
and blacklisting and taking away their
bank accounts
so the solution is for citizens you guys
out there
to lobby your state legislatures to say
we're not going to give any business to
any one of these companies
that does this we're going to divest our
pension funds our any day funds from
companies
that engage in this behavior and either
if this if you're going to get a
government contract
you're going to embrace the first
amendment you're not going to
de-platform people for legal speech
constitutionally protected um political
activity
or gainful employment so the way to get
where we're going is basically to get
these state governments on board
and one two things gonna happen okay one
two three five states
agree to this type of legislation either
the amazons the twitters the facebooks
are gonna say okay okay we are not gonna
sense your legal speech
or they're gonna say ask screw you guys
we're gonna do what we want and suddenly
there's a space for companies that do
embrace that to go after those
government contracts
to go after that money and that's how we
create this
parallel alternate ecosystem of
financial companies social media
and technical companies who embrace the
first amendment this is these government
contracts would be the seed money to
create this ecosystem
so basically the bottom line is the
state of south carolina texas oklahoma
all these states where we could
potentially pass this legislation say to
amazon to twitter to facebook look
you're not getting another penny from us
or to citibank you're not going to kick
these people off your platform because
you disagree with their
political ideas and continue to do
business with us so they'll have to make
a choice and them saying no creates a
space for these new companies to emerge
that do embrace the first amendment
what kind of money do states send uh the
way of
amazon and facebook well marketing
budgets is one thing on the socials now
that's not
that's not particularly huge but which
is much more significant is their
pension funds and rainy day funds being
invested in these companies
as well as so many government services
are dependent on contractors that use
services like amazon web services
and those other companies that uh that
discriminate the kick parlor off right
so you know if just south carolina or
just oklahoma did it
maybe it wouldn't get their attention
but you get like half the states in the
country
those are billions and billions and
billions of dollars that either they're
going to
have to change their policies to accept
or give up
and that becomes the fuel for their new
competitors who embrace the first
amendment
to get that seed money so they can grow
and compete against them
and look like i said they're entitled to
run their platforms i suppose how they
want
but they're not entitled to tax dollars
paid for by me
whose rights they're denying whose
rights of free expression and political
activity
and gainful employment they're deploying
they're denying so this is how we fight
back and
um i guess i'm going to plug this but
look ahead america we're going to train
people
next wednesday online as many as three
thousand people on how to do grassroots
lobbying
how to lobby your legislature to get
them to pass legislation like this that
says look
at facebook may kick you off but they're
not gonna get in your tax money
for advertising or marketing aws may
kick your parlor off but they're not
going to get any contracts for running
the state's medicare medicaid programs
if they're going to de-platform you so
the moment there is a legitimate legal
challenge saying
i was unjustly removed from this
platform due to my protected speech
then the state seizes ceases all
contracts and tax expenditures going to
these companies well it'll be like a
year period where they get to
disentangle from any state any uh any
entity that does not agree to
basically fulfill you know allow people
to have free speech free legal speech
without censoring it
and there's you know it's every state
has its different legal peculiarities
but we have like these are the policy
objectives very clear and simple
you get a state legislature to turn them
into the state's legislative council
it becomes legislation it goes through
hearings amendments etc
but this this is how we fight back why
don't we just have the state
legislatures pass laws saying
you can't ban people for illegal speech
well they tried that in florida i
believe it didn't go anywhere but why
not just
actually get it done because this is i
think easier because the state can
control who it does money
does contracts with you may recall the
state of california banned all travel to
other states that did not
like support bathroom laws the federal
government other states also have
writers for all their contracts that
force them to accept rules that are not
part of civil rights legislation but
sort of extend it
so this is common in government contract
and very powerful tool for reform
and it's just a lot easier than saying
hey social networks can't ban it because
then that you know it becomes a federal
matter whereas the states control
who they're going to spend with who
they're not going to spend with yeah we
saw poland recently propose
legislation that would heavily fine
social media companies for censoring
legal speech
so that's also another aspect of it but
this is interesting because many silicon
valley companies are looking to leave
california that tax-filled amazing place
that has a lot of homeless people
because of the unlivable conditions
these companies are looking to
reposition themselves so this could be
an opportunity to
to have local jurisdictions kind of step
up
i think i mean do you have high hopes of
the organ of this
being able to be organized and what
other ties do local jurisdictions have
with big tech
that could be affected here well look
all of these big tech companies
have offices in every state capital why
it's because they're going after state
government contracts
these are hundreds of billions of
trillions of dollars in state
city county spending and this matters
and again it's going to have one of two
outcomes
either they're going to forego billions
of dollars in revenue
billions of dollars that will instead go
to their competitors
brand new competitors which they hate
and fear
or they're going to have to relent and
say okay we're going to permit legal
speech we're not going to kick people
off our platform for
you know you've got banks saying that
we're going to stop doing business with
firearms manufacturers and
you know if it's your thing you know
marijuana farms right because
well this would prevent that or at least
say the state is not going to accept
payments from these banks or do
transactions through these banks if they
ban legal
it's very it's very simple whereas it
when you start banning like the behavior
or you say a social network can't ban
legal speech
you get into interstate commerce issues
and you know this maybe that company's
located another state you're going to
cough internet traffic it becomes very
complicated
whereas this is very clean cut and i
have high hopes because look
we've got a lot of people with a lot of
energy who want to do something and want
to make a difference and are fed up with
this problem
becoming us a grassroots lobbyist
becoming an
activist this is what the left has done
for so long and they've had tremendous
success with it
because they're patient with themselves
the time it took and because they were
determined they didn't give up
i know that there are at least a third
to half of the states in this country
that would eagerly pass some form of
this legislation
it's just that it has to get pushed and
nothing moves in politics unless it
pushes it's dependent on
these folks out here to to allow my
organization look at america
to organize them to guide them and to
train them on how to do this and how to
actually make it happen because we can
talk all day about all the problems in
the world
and we've but we've got enough talkers
tim does a great job we don't need
more talkers we need more doers we need
more people doing it and lobbying the
state literally and getting in their
faces on it
and the one thing that we're you know
we're trying to do especially is
building culture
so i've often talked about i'm just a
guy complaining on the internet
and so that's why for a while we've been
talking about doing this vlog where
we'll start
actually doing things and that's why
we're working on timcast.com because i'm
like i can't just keep sitting here
complaining on youtube it's ridiculous
it's okay to be a talker sometimes but
there's going to be backers there's
balance right there is about so it's
going to be yin yang we're going to do
the stuff where we're like this is bad
stuff and they're going to be like let's
make things and have fun
and inspire people to do stuff and get
them into you know i'll put it this way
we talk about it all the time the left
will play video games and they'll live
stream twitch they go on twitch they'll
play video games which i'm doing later
tonight by the way
talk more about it later while they're
playing video games and these young
people are watching minecraft or
whatever
they're talking leftist politics and it
works and
i won't twitch now because because you
know twitch is dominated by the left
they ban
people for even a moderate opinion
you're gone
so we need is we need young people who
are looking at cool
interesting things getting cheered on be
it skateboarding or music
or you know firing guns at the range
just fun stuff demolition ranch style
stuff
the kids get excited by it and then you
know what do they see in the background
of gadsden flag
so then when they try and claim the
gazing flag a symbol of white supremacy
they go
nuh-uh that skateboarder guy's got one
of those that's crazy
i won't believe it i like that guy he's
cool when they tried claiming that
pewdiepie was a white supremacist or
whatever because he said some stupid
words and made some stupid jokes
all these kids were like no he's not
you're lying
and then all of a sudden these little
kids who are like the media is lying
they're lies and then i remember the
story jake tapper said his son calls him
fake news
but think about how powerful it is they
realized this this freaked them out
and then all of a sudden the censorship
went nuts because several years ago
jake tapper said when my kids get kid
get mad gets mad at me he calls me fake
news
wow where does that kid hear that from
yeah he heard it from the likes of
pewdiepie they went after pewdiepie
hard he heard it on youtube they started
going after youtubers and purging these
channels and getting rid of them
so you got to find a way to share your
ideas
have them be peripheral to what you do
but inspire and and create and then
honestly what you're talking about as
well thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you